اولا ننتقل بكم الان الى كلمه الناطق مصم
انصار الله الحوثيين اذن للذين يقاتلون
بانهم ظلموا وان الله على نصرهم لقدير صدق
الله العظيم وبينما كانت القوات البحريه
في القوات المسلحه اليمنيه تمارس مهامها
الاعتياديه الرسميه في ترسيخ الامن
والاستقرار
وحمايه الملاحه البحريه اضافه الى اداء
واجبها الانساني والاخلاقي
الذي اعلنه اليمن في منع السفن
الاسرائيليه او المتجهه الى موانئ فلسطين
المحتله من المرور عبر البحر الاحمر
تضامنا واسناد للشعب الفلسطيني اقدمت قوات
العدو الامريكي على الاعتداء على ثلاثه
زوارق تابعه للقوات البحريه اليمنيه ما
ادى الى استشهاد وفقدان عشره افراد من
منتسب القوات البحريه ان القوات المسلحه
اليمنيه وهي تزف في خضم معركه الاسناد
لطوفان الاقصى هؤلاء الشهداء من اجل
فلسطين تؤكد ان العدو الامريكي يتحمل
تبعات هذه الجريمه
وتداعياتها وان تحركاته العسكريه في البحر
الاحمر لحمايه السفن الاسرائيليه لن تمنع
اليمن من تاديه واجبه الديني والاخلاقي
والانساني دعما ونصره للمظلومين في فلسطين
وغزه كما نهيب ببقيه الدول عدم الانخراط
في المسلك الامريكي الخطير لما سينتج عنه
من تداعيات سلبيه قد تؤثر تداعياتها على
الجميع وفي سياق اخر وبتوفيق الله نجحت
القوات البحريه في القوات المسلحه اليمنيه
في تنفيذ عمليه عسكريه استهدفت سفينه
حاويات ميرسك هانغزو كانت متجهه الى موانئ
فلسطين المحتله وذلك بصواريخ بحريه مناسبه
وقد جاءت عمليه الاستهداف بعد رفض طاقم
السفينه الاستجابه للنداءات التحذيريه
للقوات البحريه اليمنيه ان القوات المسلحه
اليمنيه تؤكد على ما جاء في بياناتها
السابقه بشان منع مرور السفن الاسرائيليه
كافه او المتجهه الى موانئ فلسطين المحتله
مع حرصها الكامل على حركه الملاحه البحريه
الى كل الوجهات باستثناء الكيان
الاسرائيلي ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه
تجدد نصحها للدول كافه بعدم الانجرار مع
مخططات الامريكي الهادفه الى اشعال الصراع
في البحر الاحمر وانها لن تتردد في التصدي
لاي عدوان ضد بلدنا وشعبنا ان القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه تهيب بابناء شعبنا اليمني
العظيم وجم جميع احرار امتنا العربيه
والاسلاميه ان يكونوا علىي على يقظه كبيره
والاستعداد للخيارات كافه في سبيل مواجهه
التصعيد الامريكي الداعم للكيان الصهيوني
المجرم والمشجع له لارتكاب المزيد من
الجرائم بحق اخواننا في غزه صنعاء الثام
عشر من جماد الاخره
1445 للهجره الموافق للحدي ديسمبر
2023 صادر عن القوات المسلحه اليمنيه